Film Courage: Has there ever been a production
that’s been easy, where it looked easy and
it was easy?
Dale Stelly, Filmmaker (COMPTON’S FINEST,
SINGLE BLACK FEMALE and more): Hhmmm?
I’d like to think about that one for a second
because to be honest none of my movie productions
were easy.
But if I had to pick one I’d probably pick
one of my first movies which is called THA’
CRIB.
It was an urban comedy that went to Blockbuster
Video.
I produced that actually with my friend Daniel
Zirilli who I mentioned earlier.
He transitioned from music videos to the movie
business and being close and working together
I was able to get one of my first movies produced
with him.
I remember it being a pleasurable experience.
I remember working with a lot of supportive
actors and friends (we all came together).
That first one is usually special.
I remember getting a lot of help with location.
I remember my friend Neal Fredericks who shot
THE BLAIR WITCH PROJECT, he shot my movie
for me.
It was just a dope experience when I think
back on it.
A lot of celebrities visited the set while
we were shooting at my parent’s house.
Now that I think back on it, yes THA’ CRIB
was probably a fun shoot that didn't turn
into a headache.
Sometimes these are supposed to be fun shoots.
Sometimes when you’re dealing with money
and time and certain people not respecting
the creative process you have to deal with
certain things that take the fun out of it.
But that one was fun, everything worked out
and on top of it I had no idea that was going
to go to Blockbuster and be everywhere that
it was so for me to be working full-time in
a post house.
I think I was working at The Vault at the
time and my movie came out in Blockbuster
was like pretty cool.
I was like the all-star at the company for
a couple of years or whatever and I was putting
my movies out.
People were trying to figure out how are you
doing this?
Like how did you shoot a movie and you are
working here full-time?
I just didn’t sleep a lot.
And I found ways to shoot three movies without
losing my job at the post house.
I used a lot of my vacation, I was strategic
with my vacation days.
And I remember working night shift as a film
scan and recording operator and I remember
staying up for a period of almost eight days
straight.
I think I stayed up three days straight and
then went to sleep and then stayed up another
three days straight and went to sleep because
my company wouldn’t let me take time off
and I worked a night shift so I got my mind
mentally stabilized and I wanted to stay up
because they told me if I was unable to direct
my movie, they were going to get another director.
But the movie wasn’t paying me enough to
quit my job.
So I had to make sure I kept my post job which
was obviously paying all my bills and everything
and this one movie.
It was my third or fourth movie called SWEET
POTATO PIE.
But I remember working a night shift.
And I remember the way I worked it out I got
out at 6:00 in the morning and I had call-time
at 8:00 in the morning so I literally stayed
up…I made sure to start shooting on a Wednesday
because I was off on the weekends.
So I stayed up Wednesday, Thursday, Friday
straight (I don’t know how I did it) but
my whole system was get off of work at 6:00
a.m., get home, shower, and I was ready for
8:00 a.m. call-time.
Then I worked on set from 8:00 a.m. to 8:00
p.m. and then I was able to take a nap for
an hour or so to get to work for a 10:00 p.m.
because I worked from 10:00 p.m. to 6:00 a.m.
And I did that literally for three days straight.
I remember the only way I stayed up was I
had something to do every second every minute
for the last 36 hours.
The job that I had required me to be attentive,
be with the computer with the film scan outs
and I was on coffee and I remember having
my friend videotape me as proof that I was
pulling off this miraculous situation with
directing a movie that ended up going to Lionsgate.
My first movie goes to Lionsgate and I’m
working in scanning and recording at the time
(it was 2002 or 2003).
But yes, it was a crazy feel when you are
passionate and dedicated and you have a chance
and opportunity and I chose to keep both.
I was like man I can’t quit my job because
I was making under $10,000 or something for
doing a movie.
It should have been way more than that but
yes, that was a pretty interesting situation
when I pulled off the movie SWEET POTATO PIE.
I did the urban version to the successful
film which was called AMERICAN PIE.
So I was known for coming up with these spin-offs
of these successful films.
Like SINGLE WHITE FEMALE, I did SINGLE BLACK
FEMALE.
PASSION OF THE CHRIST, I did JC IN THE HOOD.
AMERICAN PIE, I did SWEET POTATO PIE and these
were titles that I picked and knew were going
to be sure shots with at least getting my
name and stuff out there.
Because when you’re shooting you want to
make sure that you’re shooting things that
are going to sell.
You don’t want to shoot things that aren’t
going to sell.
So I always picked things that were super
successful and then I flipped it to be like
what would it be like if it was made in the
inner of Los Angeles, you know what I mean?
That template for me worked a lot…it still
works actually.
Film Courage: Would you actually walk into
Blockbuster?
How would you approach Blockbuster video?
Dale: Oh, no I would get a distribution deal
that would just put me everywhere.
Film Courage: Oh I see…so you actually never
tried to go in.
Dale: I never had to deal with the Blockbuster
executives or accounts or whatever.
My distribution deal which was by a major
distributor had the relationships with the
major studios.
So once you sell your film to major studio
like Lionsgate, they make sure that it comes
out on TV and DVD and everywhere that a movie
like that would be seen.
Film Courage: How was that to go into Blockbuster
and see your film?
Dale: It was phenomenal because I remember
like one year I had three or four movies on
Blockbuster at one time and it was a crazy
feeling where it actually transitioned to
everything becoming digital and everything
being streamed online.
At the time I had like three or four movies
at Blockbuster at one time and it was a very
good feeling to walk into Blockbuster and
see my movies next to like The Rock, Samuel
Jackson or Will Smith.
It was a pretty good feeling to see that my
hard work ended up on a major shelf and that’s
what gave me the energy to keep going more
and to shoot for bigger and better films and
I’m still here.
I’ve just got my first movie in a theater
(COMPTON’S FINEST) which we released through
Cinemark and it did pretty well and I’m
expecting to release more movies this year
independently through the theater.
I figured that out now.
I figured it all the way out now from script
to the big screen as an independent production
company it’s very hard to…I don’t want
to say master…but to kind of figure all
that out.